[Music]
last night's democratic forum on cbs
wasn't the final primary debate of this
season but it's likely the last one that
will matter
between tonight and the next debate a
total of 21 states and that includes the
biggest ones california and texas
will hold their primaries by then it
will almost certainly be over
so you'd think the candidates would use
the time to talk about things that
voters care deeply about
and for a brief moment one of them
actually did that in his first answer
bernie sanders brought up
wages he said they ought to rise faster
which is true now how could wages
possibly go
up with the open borders sanders is
demanding that's an unanswerable
question but at least he mentioned it
and that's exactly why he's a
front-runner when you talk about things
people care about
they respond michael bloomberg is not
the frontrunner he'd like to be
when given his chance to speak bloomberg
went right to the issue he believes
voters care about
most the fact that bernie sanders is a
secret russian agent
vladimir putin thinks that donald trump
is should be president united states
and that's why russia is helping you get
elected
[Applause]
so that's what bloomberg's consultants
told him to say
lesson here is obvious go into political
consulting even
dumb people get rich at least one
audience in america was powerfully moved
by bloomberg's attack
the other candidates at the very mention
of vladimir putin the stage erupted
suddenly debate sounded like a radical
book club from the 1970s
old people yelling about the cold war
russia russia russia
pete but a judge who was 38 but seems at
least a century older
jumped in with his theory what trump and
his pay master vladimir putin
actually want explain the tiny robot
from south bend
is political chaos but a judge seems
totally convinced that no one had ever
said that before
by this point the moderators at cbs just
gave up the chaos putin is hoping for
descended on the debate stage sanders
decided it was a perfect opportunity
to indulge his real passion which is
attacking america
a country he clearly hates here he has
explained that the american criminal
justice system
is actually more repressive than
communist china's
we have a criminal justice system today
that is not only broken it is racist got
more people in jail than any other
country on earth including
china one of the reasons for that is a
horrific
war on drugs oh
the war on drugs bernie sanders talks
about that in every speech he gives
a declining country with a sad
underemployed middle class
obviously needs to smoke a ton more weed
that's bernie's solution to the malaise
fire up a bowl numb out maybe you won't
notice
so where's all this weed gonna come from
well bernie's got a plan for that too
black people are going to sell it to you
no kidding
watch this and i'll tell you what else
we're going to do
we're going to provide help to the
african-american latino native american
community
to start businesses to sell legal
marijuana
rather than let a few corporations
control
the legalized marijuana market
that's a real clip by the way so first
they fill black neighborhoods with
abortion clinics now their front runner
is encouraging more black kids to sell
drugs but somehow
this is the party that loves black
america doesn't sound like
it but whatever joe biden soon changed
the subject by making very loud noises
biden has lost his ability to speak
clearly and that's got to be frustrating
for anyone
in biden's case it's led to a series of
rage eruptions
watch you talk about what we're talking
about with bernie
bernie in fact hasn't passed much of
anything the fact of the matter is
i get to answer that look the fact is
here's the deal i'm not out of time you
spoke over time and i'm going to talk
here's the deal
look at what's happening here look at
what's happening here
the crowd roared because screaming
always elicits roars from crowds or
animal brains at work
but for those who are trying to follow
what biden was actually saying deaf
people for example reading it at home on
closed caption
it was a profoundly confusing moment by
the end biden's train of thought didn't
simply get lost
it hopped the tracks and became a fiery
derailment plunging off the bridge into
the gorge below
and i would make it clear i'd make it
clear to china
we are going to continue to move closer
to make sure that we can
in fact prevent china prevent north
korea from
launching missiles to take them down and
if we don't
why am i stopping no one else stops okay
why am i stopping he asked well because
disjointed sentence fragments are
counterproductive in a presidential
campaign
the good news is at least biden still
knows a verbal cul-de-sac when he hits
one a few months from now
he'll be resetting alan ginsberg poems
to strangers at bus stops he's going
fast
elizabeth warren was there too last
night warren is not going to be
president that's a good thing she's
awful
maybe the most unpleasant human being
ever to run for president in this
country
you'd be in paraguay by the end of the
first elizabeth warren administration
just to stop the noise
warren seems to know this she can tell
that she is doomed if nothing else she's
not stupid
and she's decided to spend her remaining
time destroying michael bloomberg
and really that's a nice way to go out
if you think about it it's a service to
the country
unfortunately last night it didn't work
instead warren just humiliated herself
i was visibly pregnant the principal
wished me luck and gave my job to
someone else
pregnancy discrimination you bet but i
was 21 years old
i didn't have a union to protect me i
didn't have any federal law
on my side so i packed up my stuff and i
went home
at least i didn't have a boss who said
to me
kill it the way that
said that mayor bloomberg said to one of
his pregnant
employees
wait a second we have news emerging did
you just hear elizabeth warren say there
are circumstances in which encouraging
abortion might be
wrong don't tell planned parenthood
she'll lose her funding
meanwhile warren's story about her own
pregnancy the one you just heard could
have been the most depressing moment of
the night
the story is a lie everyone knows it is
it's been conclusively debunked
by her on tape but warren keeps telling
the story anyway with exactly the same
inflections and pauses and hand gestures
keep in mind this is a person who was
once a tenured harvard law professor
she wrote a genuinely good book at one
point people respected her
now well now warren's up there degrading
herself with some transparent
whopper designed to show you how
oppressed she is
ugh by the time this is over warren will
be hillary clinton
pacing her backyard with a bottle of
wine and sending bitter tweets about
trump at midnight
no normal person will have lunch with
her after this it's pathetic and sad
but it's not just her it's universal
this year everyone
in the democratic field has been greatly
diminished by this
and it's not because they're all bad
people not all of them are bad people
it's because their ideas are absurd